to go and rest my eyes peered apart but
I have a unibrow what the hell are you
talking about
anyway welcome to mis ow I wonder
[ __ ] I found a pot of miss our missile I
haven't found you oh did it a day I
found a dead head yeah the hell is it
doing here though alright this is [ __ ]
creeping me out man
alright well at least we can say the
teacher now without in [ __ ] murdering
us that [ __ ] [ __ ] ass I don't like I
do not like tit well I'm relation parody
now
where the hell was he where the hell was
he it was in one of the classrooms no
it's not here [ __ ] have you ever [ __ ]
it up
I'm just asking geez alright fine
don't [ __ ] it up then I don't really do
it okay okay okay don't [ __ ] kill me
I'm a woman look inside teacher pad pad
thank goodness I'm beat I pass out after
that quake and I woke up a locked inside
a locker naturally it's assigned out to
be open from the inside the school looks
odd I'm going to look around teacher is
dangerous
is that it he went is he going to be
okay probablemente no he's like the only
one has to die is this [ __ ] gonna [ __ ]
with me again yeah Cheers
[ __ ] you well I don't done diddly no
there is a lot of clues here but
I don't know open the locket yes oh okay
don't open that knocker okay I got it
that's nice Shipka okay finally geez
okay and mr. Sultan what what are you
two doing she's underage woman help
Hika calm down the most argonautica
pitcher might have a die again she was
in panic after being attacked by mozzie
okay you were attacked
I told you to escape somewhere safe hold
on you should stay with a head rested we
can have a threesome
but don't worry I'll be with her all
right I'm counting on you to look after
I okay I'll look around a bit more wait
a moment I think I have a tranquilizer
on my desk in the staff room could you
bring it to me it may help her calm down
a little
got it be careful I don't want to die
out there you're one of my best students
sir thank you very [ __ ] much thank
you thank you all right where was his
stupid [ __ ] room I don't [ __ ]
carrot thing let's just think here
that's just not there it's probably not
here let's check it that is here I'm a
genius
where is my genius award I've been
waiting a long time for my genius award
and that one keeps giving at her desk a
tranquilizer I don't see a tranquilizer
he [ __ ] luck he lied he tracked back
I don't you know drag belch
oh no park everything about you oh no
you don't take pills or he's gonna pay
for this you're a track bar you track
Mac Ayaka hey I gotta wake up Ayaka I'm
sorry a monster pal don't know where I
couldn't do a thing dab it I fail to
protect my students sniff please sir
don't be so hard on yourself it's all in
the space to blame we don't have we have
to do something
hm what what wait you're hurt to have to
care for this I'll be fine just do what
needs to be done right take this
find this while looking around what the
[ __ ] is that Oh what the [ __ ] she
visited me the day before she went
missing she had something to talk about
but I was so busy I didn't have time to
listen to her and now she was paying I
can't help but feel if I heard her out
she never would have left us well I'm
not fit to save her you're the only one
who can missiles armed did it today well
I don't [ __ ] trust you
I can't inspect her what happens if I
sleep now
sure why not still [ __ ] creeping me
out man stay on the [ __ ] creep inside
Wow let's get Galan all right Charlotte
uh-huh we didn't check out you can now
use the warp function okay without a Sam
Bay ring command press the shadow key
while exploring to open ring c'mon okay
so now I can warp in [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah what she said you're in the
City Council room ah I'm I am Fidelia
what's up I remember in my name I'm so
glad sigh how many years has it been
since I talked to anyone ha but there
they are please be my friend already oh
you don't want to I'll be your friend
really I'm so sad you're my first friend
this library it's kind of awkward though
what's your real name
well then mr. Theodore please give me an
easier name yes I want to marvelous name
watch oh gosh what's this gonna be
well
ah whoa no no there we go
that's wonderful name from now on call
me lead pack surge sigh friend that
sounds good
she's in love with me well I gotta be
going Fidelia if you ever run in trouble
please come visit me I don't know how
useful I can be but I'll do what I can't
drop okay [ __ ] shut up
haha hey we are back in black I am
wearing black genius nochang I asked
Alice could I have remembered something
that you've probably been face palming a
lot about while watching the last
episode now think about it and it's the
fact that oh I was right [ __ ] there
I'm such a native um in the beginning of
the game I shot you're such an attention
[ __ ] or now you don't want to show
yourself [ __ ] right here there's like a
phaser or whatever that I've been
wanting to break a vase it's fixed to
the table destroy it I can do it now
because you have the baseball back
somebody I'm out of the bay emergency
exit key so now we can live isn't that
wonderful you I guess we can really
leave scalice shut up such an
intentional all right here it is this
should work there we go oh [ __ ]
just don't kill me if I look at your
face JD has pen strikes again okay shed
what why did that cool doll oh it's that
guy I forgot about him good day oh yeah
I gotta make myself pretty you're hurt
are you all right
a monster got me I tried to run but I
sprained my leg
and hats hell what that voice missile
guru can hear - masala is in pain damn
if I only had been quicker to say miss
out khuda masala and I were together
since kindergarten we played together
all the time in middle school I was
teased for playing with a girl so I
tried to avoid me Sam you should have
stayed with our band when I learned miss
I was being bullied I didn't help her
and now I'm sorry miss ow sorry I
couldn't help you I'll be there soon
I'm always beside you so don't cause any
more sadness okay miss ow
Oh hack go go go help or watch I just
watch just gonna help pick up play oh
I'm gonna die now oh I need to click
give up come on don't be a [ __ ] well
that means we got to do that [ __ ] again
alright so I guess I gotta choose watch
right I'll just watch
miss ow came to meet me now we'll always
be together okay I love you
wow really well that's a plot twist
you're mistaken I never liked you at all
miss aw come on don't be such a boner
killer now die actually that might me
Wow Wow
this is awful what was that what was
that
what was the point of all this and get
any item that's bullish well they're all
that now that's gosh edge [ __ ] creeps
me out man [ __ ] girls keep following
me well the game is saved we are still
carrying that I got the parts so I only
got two parts that's not good I need to
go to the nursery
what is it padilha help Tama please it's
my classmate oh he can help them yeah
this should be good leave hacks Sertoma
stay here for a while the spirits don't
seem to come here whoa I can't do that
not with this mysterious man it's just
my classmate Tama
that was not that scary I swear sir
please oh well views legs are pretty
well here best voice ever um wow this is
gonna be okay huh what a [ __ ] is there
gonna be fine or why he's gonna die I'm
gonna die
mmm-hmm
let's look for more take them out of the
way whether I get lilies okay rumor has
it that president only Guevara as a
hidden C okay so the lilies that I just
found are a clue to this thing and it's
supposed to say which classroom I go to
to a I don't know why to be and three C
I'm supposed to check the desks to find
the vases and then put lilies in each
one of them uh-huh
Bedelia I'm another you we have never
met but that is our fate regardless I've
been watching over you
wonderful so which classroom is is this
how do I know which classroom is each
but there's something in the locker pick
it up yes place there's a locker key
teacher must have dropped it I got a
locker key wonderful uh-huh so I got a
check in all these desks there's amazing
two desk uh-huh and then we put lilies
in it that's wonderful WAM decorating
pads strikes again this wrote ash
fabulous lady number okay the other
classroom is to be it's gotta be over
here right yep and which [ __ ] one
will it be
well I'll just do the pit of highway to
solve things not using your brain just
aimlessly try [ __ ] everything there
we go
works every time nope why the hell did I
do that no no no bad pits we're not
gonna alright and the last one is on
this floor and we're gonna done diddly
put it on three see that's gotta be here
yep tiny head pear strikes again
checking that Oh second try margaritas I
hear your voice from nowhere
I'm waiting on their rooftop well it's
gonna be some let's go action going on
if I'm correct Amanda where's the
rooftop it's over here I hope you
brought that yardas app it's out back in
fairness you did subscribe to my
birthday I'll see you next episode
fly moment I'll be buzzed stay